uh good morning i'm hap my name is
catherine gordon and i'm happy to be
giving today's webinar
uh entitled lessons learned from
targeting the oncogene eif4e and
leukemia where eif4e stands for the
eukaryotic initiation factor eif4e
um i'm a professor at the institute for
research in immunology and cancer
at the university of montreal and i'm
also being asked to remind you that this
talk is you can get cme credits for
there's a button to press on on a cme
button for you to press in order to do
that
so let's get started
um
why why target eif4e which is our
nickname or 4e which is our nickname for
the ukr eukaryotic initiation uh
transition initiation factor 4e
well 4e leads to transformation in cell
culture and animal models and rescue
cells from apoptotic stimuli
eif4e
is overexpressed in 30 of human cancers
and this is linked to poor prognosis
and as i'll show you today we actually
um cancer cells over expressing foray
actually develop an oncogene dependency
or addiction thereby providing a
therapeutic window for targeting eif4e
these are just a short list of some of
the cancers that eif4e has been shown to
be upregulated in i am particularly
going to focus today on acute myeloid
leukemia specifically the m4 and m5
subtypes however our findings are also
applicable to some other subtypes as
well but you can see that a wide variety
of hematological and solid malignancies
also have care are characterized by high
4e i should note that some of them such
as head and neck cancer have about 99
penetrance of high eif4e whereas some of
the other cancers will be specific
subgroups that are high for e and
specific subgroups that have other uh
underlying
issues
um i won't have a chance to really
discuss this question in detail but how
does the effort become elevated in these
malignancies is obviously incredibly
important we have um
a couple of models i'm showing here you
have increased stability of the fourier
transcript by
another oncogene hur you can have gene
amplification of eif4e and you can also
see increased rna levels through
increased transcription and i should
note that some of these can actually act
together so multiple pathways can work
simultaneously
the effects of eif4e are specific so
many of you who will have
be familiar with eif4e as a standard
translation factor will think that it
affects all genes
equally and what i want to show you here
is that eif4e and as can be shown by
this early study from 1993 that eif4e
overexpression does not change the
cellular proteome if it has effects that
are specific
and um this is in on the on the left is
a case of looking at fourier over
expression and on the right is a case of
looking at antisense oligos where again
you can see that over expression of 4a
does not cause a global change in
translation rates
it it affects specific transcripts
furthermore the localization of 4e is
not is not always cytoplasmic it can be
both
nuclear and cytoplasmic so hopefully you
can see um
that in for instance if we develop if we
take embryonic stem cells
and we differentiate them into
macrophages if we're looking at these
various stages of macrophage development
that eif for relocalization changes
quite dramatically
to being in some cases mainly nuclear to
being mainly cytoplasmic to being again
a mixture of nuclear and cytoplasmic
so this this protein which is a
traditional translation factor and as
you know translation traditionally
occurs in the cytoplasm um also has a
substantial nuclear localization which
is context dependence and other species
such as drosophila the fruit fly or
yeast also have nuclear as well as
cytoplasmic eif4e
so if we think of the traditional view
of eif4e by looking at the cytoplasmic
cytoplasmic content of 4e what you're
looking at here in the cytoplasmic arm
is first we have the structure of
eiforce solved by steve burley's lab
many years ago
and this here in yellow is the methyl7
guanosine cap which is attached to mrnas
and is how fourier associates with rnas
and recruits uh transcripts to
the
ribosome
these rnas
must have a complex five prime
untranslated region in order to be
foreign targets and they also recruit a
whole mishmash of translation machinery
which we will go into the details of
today in order to recruit the transcript
to
the um
ribosome
we have specific inhibitors such as the
four ebps that can stop this process
and i
we have many transcripts that are
specifically sensitive so when you over
express 4e the efficiency of their
translation is elevated and these
include ornithine decarboxylase and
vascular endothelial growth factor as
well as many others
other genes are housekeeping genes such
as gap dh don't have their translation
efficiency modulated by
eif4e
this cytoplasmic arm eventually
contributes to proliferation and
apoptotic rescue functions and
ultimately oncogenic transformation
activities that one associates with 4e
but importantly there is also a nuclear
arm to 4e and as i'll discuss today this
nuclear arm is also relevant to the
ability of 4e to oncogenically transform
cells the same structure is shown and
the same requirement for the m7g cap is
in order for rnas to bind 4e is true in
the nucleus as well as the cytoplasm
we can also see that a specific subset
of factors distinct from the translation
machinery associate with 4e and are
important for its ability to export a
specific subset of rnas and these
specific subsets of rnas
contain what we refer to as a 4z or 4e
sensitivity element and you can see the
secondary structure
defined here so this is a secondary
structure element which is transferable
to rna such as lac zed and can enable
them to become fourier sensitive
other
are
specific proteins or specific nuclear
set of inhibitors for this function
including the ring domain of the
promylistic leukemia protein
the
hematopoietically expressed tomato
domain hex also known as proline
retrometer main and many others are
regulators of this nuclear process
this process is distinct from bulk rna
export it requires crim1 whereas bulk
rna export uses the tac-1 and xf1
receptor and again this this process is
also cap dependent just like translation
some rnas that are specifically targeted
by the
in the export arm include cyclin d1 mrna
and odc mrna we can fractionate cells
into nuclear and cytoplasmic fractions
and directly observe
the modulation of rna export and it's
estimated that it's probably around 700
transcripts i note that some of these
targets such as odc
are targets of both the export and
translation functions of 4e making them
potent
potent effectors for the potent effector
of their expression
other transcripts such as vegf
are only translation targets
and cyclin d1 seems to be mainly an rna
export target together these functions
in in nuclear and cytoplasmic functions
of 4e contribute to the proliferation
and apototic rescue functions that have
been attributed to the physiological
activities of 4e and help drive
oncogenic transformation
so
another way to sum this up is that
effort coordinately regulates
transcripts involved in the same
biochemical pathways so it
it exports and as a group cyclins for
instance and helps cell cycle
progression that way
and it always requires is bethel seven
guanosine cat binding activity for this
so let's look at what effort looks like
in human malignancy
here what you're looking at is cd34
positive cells isolated from a healthy
individual where in green is the 4e and
you can see you have both the nuclear
bodies and also a rim i remind you these
blood cells don't have they have very
small cytoplasm
in the
uh malignant case we can see we have
some cytoplasmic foray obviously but we
have a lot more new we have a lot more
flurry in general and this is sort of
chock a block within the nucleus of this
aml patient cd34 positive set of cells
if we
look on to um
to
the western blot to look at 40 levels
between healthy individuals
and patients we can see fourier levels
are highly elevated and cyclin d1 and
rna export target are also highly
elevated
if we look at total rna and this is
using northern blots we see that our
cyclin d1 rna is not elevated at all so
this is a post-transcriptional event
and if we take our cells doing another
northern blot and look at rna export by
looking at the nuclear and cytoplasmic
functions
of um
fractions of the cells we can see
if we compare a normal cell to an aml or
a blast crisis cml specimen that we have
highly elevated rna export for cyclin d1
transcripts relative to um to the normal
controls indicating that this fraction
of 4e
is
in the nucleus of the aml cells is
highly active in rna export
so we wanted to i want to take a few
slides to show you some work that we can
explain that
first of all how does fourier dependent
rna export work what's the mechanism
underlying that
and is there a link between rna export
and the transformation activities of 4e
and i'll certainly show you that that's
the case
um
this is a brief summary and we have much
more data than what i have time to show
you here on that um and this work is
done mainly by billionaire
klitschkovitch scratchlich and orli
baggay
so our our model and i'll show you uh
the model first
and then the date some of the data that
supports it is
that if we have two arms we have a we
have the
normal condition this side
where
uh
where rnas exit the the nuclear pore
complex where you can see the nuclear
basket and these are the cytoplasmic
fibrils the rna cargoes get released by
attaching onto the fibrils and they can
go off into the cytoplasm and um
and be
translated oh and the export factors can
be
re-imported to them into the nucleus for
future rounds of export
now if we take the condition what we
have high for you we actually see that
the eif4e over expression
will change the structure of the nuclear
pore and i remind you that the nuclear
pore is the um
only two main means of four of of uh
macromolecules transiting between the
nuclear cytoplasmic compartments
so in this high eif40 case what we find
is or was reorganization of
of the cytoplasmic side mainly of the
nuclear pore we see a loss of nuclear
poron 214
from the nuclear side going to the
cytoplasmic side
and what we see most strikingly is a
substantial reduction in the number of
the amount of ram bp2 and ramping p2 is
the protein that is key for making these
characteristic cytoplasmic fibrils as a
way to compensate for that what happens
in fourier overexpressing cells is that
around bp1 another small around gtpase
is becomes overexpressed and this allows
increased release rates of cargoes as
they come into the cytoplasm where
there's no longer any steric hindrance
due to having to bind the cytoplasmic
fibril but rather now everything is is
coming in within the soluble fraction of
the cell allowing a faster release rate
and faster re-import
of of the um
the to recycle the export machinery and
a faster release allowing um a better
better access of the rna or faster
access to the rna to translation
machinery
so what this what we can see here when
we look at the data is for instance by
over expressing 4e we see substantial
reduction in ram bp2 consistent with
what i'm telling you here that there's a
substantial loss of the cytoplasmic
fibrils and that these proteins like
round vp1 become highly elevated to
compensate and allow for cargo release
to happen in the soluble compartments
um so what we summarize here is that
fourier affects the cargo release step
rate in in this process by increasing
soluble around vp1 levels enhancing
recycling of export
factors and release of cargos
so let's explore this a little bit more
so around vp2 this protein i just told
you about is a key nuclear pore
protein important to the cytoplasmic
fibril
we asked the question
why would you want to do this in terms
of of transformation does it have an rna
export rates
you know what what's the evidence i can
provide for the model i've just shown
and that's what i'm going to show you
here
is that the ram bp2 nuclear pore protein
suppresses for you mediated rna export
but it doesn't touch bulk rna exports so
this is specific
um
if we take two types of rnas we either
have lac zed rna or laxat rna it
contains our 4z elements so this one is
sensitive to eif4e
and at the same time we over express a
specific part around bp2 which contains
zinc fingers
um and we know it's important for the
process that we're looking at because
that's required for interaction with the
nuclear export receptor crim1
and what you can see
is by western blot is that
overexpression of random p2 does not
really affect levels of plane laxat but
it causes a substantial reduction of
lac said
4z rna as you can see here
if we go over and we see if whether this
is at the export
at the export step or not what this what
this graph here is showing you
is that
as the rna levels in the nucleus versus
a cytoplasm where cells were
fractionated and rna is analyzed by qpcr
and so in these first two lanes this is
looking at plane lax zed and it's not
affected um which is
understandable because it doesn't
contain a forza element it's not a
fourier target
lack said 4z export is increased merely
because it has the 4z element in this
context of over 40 over expression and
when you add randy p2 you substantially
suppress this
and if we now look at an endogenous rna
cmic which is also a 4e target
we can see that in both cases this
endogenous rna has its export suppressed
by over expressing
around vp2 consistent with the fact that
mick contains a 4z element and that
makes a fourier target
finally ubiquitin our negative control
is unaffected and to note total rna is
unaffected so what can we conclude from
this um
is that rbp2 the ramp2 nuclear pore
protein which makes cytoplasmic fibril
actually suppresses fourier mediated rna
export but not bulk export and so we
presume that by reducing your mbp2
levels fourier can can transform cells
more readily
so let's look into that question
for if we have here we have cells over
expressing
4e
plus round ep 2
and here we have cells only expressing
40 plus the vector control and this is
the quantitation of this experiment and
you can see that you have uh ram vp2
suppressing substantially suppressing
fourier's oncogenic transformation
activity
by simply over expressing this one
fragment of ram bp2 consistent with our
model that is suppressing the rna export
function it's also suppressing the
transformation function
and i would also like to just note to
you that rambi p2 hypomorph mice get
spontaneous tumors more readily than
controls which is consistent with what
what we're saying here whereas over
expression actually would
um suppress this
so
to continue on um this vein we found a
fourier mutant
that
um that acts in translation s53a
but does not alter around bp2
cannot form a nuclear rnp
cannot export rnas and cannot transform
cells so let's show you a little of the
evidence for that
so in this set of western flats you can
see here 4e nicely suppresses ram bp2
whereas s53a looks very much like the
negative control 56a
um
and if we look
here we can see that this is this is
vector this is fourier over expression
and this is s53a
and here the experiment is simply being
an rna uh rip
with four e antibody and so in the
nucleus wild type 4e eyepiece with
ornate decarboxylase and with ram bp1
but the s53a mutant does not nor does
the s53a mutant bind with any rnas in
the nucleus that we've actually been
able to um
to identify of many that we've examined
however s53a mutant is still active in
translation in fact the s53a mutant
can actually
rescue yeast which are deficient in wild
type eif4e and just to demonstrate that
point a little bit here what you can see
is that both wild type
and s53a mutant binds uh 4e in the
cytoplasm find odc rna in a cytoplasm
similarly for around vp1 or any other
rna that we've tested and here is simply
the vector control
so the s53a mutants effects are
specifically nuclear um it's or i should
say its deficits are specifically
nuclear where it is completely active in
the cytoplasm
so if we look at anchorage independent
growth which measures the loss of
contact inhibition what we can see here
is that if you over express 4e you
obviously have many foci here's the
vector control and then the s53a mutant
has completely lost its ability to
transform cells
although it retains the ability to
translate rna
so this really strongly suggests that
the nuclear functions of 4e are relevant
for its transformation potential at
least in the context that we've been
looking
so given that we had
been able to show that foreign was
highly elevated in specific subsets of
aml and that this nuclear rna export
function was was very high
and given that we can show you that the
rna export function is related to
transformation we were very keen to
target fluoride dependent export in aml
patients this acute myeloid leukemia now
for those of you who are not familiar
the the overall survival in aml is is
not very good and the standard of care
has been the same since the 1970s
so
in in aml currently you have a median
survival of seven months for most
patients
um these are patients who are receiving
intensive chemo um
and that's despite an initial 50 or so
complete remission rate these patients
will all relapse and and um not do very
well median survival is five months for
patients who receive non-intensive chemo
three months for best supportive care
and as i said the standard of care is
unchanged since 1970s
so we identified a means to
biochemically inhibit 4e and i should
say this has an effect both it inhibits
translation and export functions of 4e
which is probably one of its strengths
but let me just go through some of the
data to show you that this is really
an inhibitor so we've done many
experiments and i've just made a little
one slide summary
for instance this work here this mass
back work is done by um uh old student
alex kansas who now has his own lab it's
on kettering
and what you can see is if you mix
apo eif4e with with both gtp and
ribovarin you see peaks for the 804e for
the ribovarian 4e but there's no peak
for the g for the gtp 4e when gtp is our
negative control so that's good so what
that means is that by mass spec we can
identify the radicand for a complex
um work also done by alex showed the uh
by simple cap competition
uh column where you add a 4e to to a
column where you have a cap resin and
then you can either
use high levels of cap analog m7 gtp or
high levels of the active metabolite of
radovir and rtp you can
you can while you can compete off the 4e
with similar efficient with similar
efficiency yielding similar kis
a similar experiment was done by uh ivan
takasirovic who is now at mcgill as an
assistant professor and you can see that
um
the same idea of a cap column where gtp
and gppg cannot compete for e off
whereas
rtp or cap analog methylated cap analog
seven gdp or m7 gppg i'll efficiently um
do so again indicating this is this is
all using purified components then four
is directly binding the um
is directly binding uh the ribovarin
finally we've also done nmr experiments
these are done by mike osborne and
laurent volpon here in montreal
university of montreal and we can see
that um
that ribover and binding causes chemical
ship perturbations or changes to the to
the
physic changes indicating that it's
binding to to the to eif4 using nmr
methods and so these changes are mapped
here
um on the fourier nmr structure and also
just to show you for instance in
in red is apo
4e and in blue
is rtp bound fourier so we can see
dramatic changes for instance f48 is
deep within the 4e pocket
pointed out here
consistent with the fact that rhinoderm
is binding directly into the cap binding
pocket either overlapping in a similar
position to to the cap itself
of course biophysics is lovely but does
that really happen in the cell so we've
carried out a couple of experiments to
show you here actually um this is from
willis miller's lab and particularly
philippa peterson
who showed that if you take breast
cancer cells um and you knock down
fourier as you can see here
that
if you take the cells by their control
10 micromolar 20 micromolar rib of urine
that in the cells that you knock down 4e
ribavia no longer has an effect
consistent with the fact that you've
sort of removed the drug target so
there's no longer an ability to further
suppress
um the the growth
and similarly
she carried out a attributed ribovarian
ip experiment where cells are treated
with treated ribovariant and
immunoprecipitated with fluori antibody
and you can see quite a substantial
enrichment
in um
4e
versus um
versus the igg control indicating that
within styles rybav and fourier
interacting as well
so we decided to go ahead and carry out
a phase two clinical trial at first
in refractory and relapsed m4 and m5aml
patients uh this was a multi-center
effort including uh opi salmeisen of
rosemont the jewish general hospital and
street gasoline is the the lead on the
study um coordinating all the sites um
brian libroso mcmaster um
and out of our out of our 15 invaluable
patients we had six with with uh with
responses
one cr which lasted nine months two
partial remissions
three blast responses which is a
reduction of the amount of leukemia
blasts
by 50 or greater six stable diseases and
three patients that never responded
one of the partial remissions actually
had regression of leukemic skin lesions
or a leukemia leukemia cutis indicating
that we could target outside of the
blood compartment
so given the the
the dreadful prognosis of this disease
and the fact that these patients have
all failed other
standard treatments and other
experimental treatments we found that
these really striking results and so
what we did is we we went on to try a
combination study of riborum plus low
dose rc in a phase one trial
oh we found out here a couple of things
first of all that uh subcutaneous error
c actually
impeded the oral absorbance of ribovirin
and so we had to do a lot of work on our
pk and i would suggest anyone doing
trials would would really double check
their pk to be sure that their
absorbance into the plasma is as
expected
um of our patients only of the 29
patients we only had 14 that had um
because of this problem
sort of a correct level of of um
of ribovarin in their plasma
so of these we had very striking
responses again we had one a woman who
had breast cancer
had a secondary to a breast cancer
therapy um and she had a 24 month
response when
we had another patient who had a six
month response with his cr we had one pr
and
he had to come off steady because of
of a dose limiting toxicity but he was
responding at the time we had a couple
of blast responses and a couple of
strong um
stable diseases
so we felt that um
although positive and that these results
really recapitulate a lot the rc didn't
make a dramatic difference
but we could see clearly for retargeting
and we could clearly um see foreign
targeting was only happening in the
patients that were having a clinical
response
so let me show you that
so this is one of the patients from the
ribovarian monotherapy trial who
achieved the patient who achieved the
complete remission which he achieved in
the first 28 days and you can see
the bone marrow smears here but we can
also look at fourier
staining in this
gentleman and you can see the 4e is
highly highly nuclear look very much
like the aml specimens i showed you
before and what we noticed after 28 days
is
when he was first achieving his uh
clinical
well start of his clinical remission you
could see the 4e is now much more
cytoplasmic and much more reduced and
i'll explain why that happens it's part
of for retargeting of ribogram targeting
its fourteen
we could direct i'll explain how that
happens in in probably about 15 minutes
and what we can also see here is that
this reduction in nucleophile
corresponded to reduction in rna export
of transcripts and
of elevated transcripts in
in patients at response and so this is
another patient just to show you that it
was for more than one patient and you
can see at zero this is the rna export
of nbs1 and at 28 days is substantially
reduced and this is just looking at a
secondary transcript to show it wasn't
something specific to only nbs1
so what we can see from this is that we
have a nice molecular response we have
inhibition of rna export unfortunately
we don't have enough material from
patients to do polygonal loading to look
at translational efficiency but we
certainly are targeting 4e
and
the 4a localization actually turns out
to be really relevant to clinical
response having this localization
pattern here is a harbinger of clinical
response and when patients relapse the
localization goes back to the before
picture which is usually a hard figure
of
clinical relapse
so let's just summarize this again in
this slide for instance this is the
patient who uh responded for for two
years so this is her before treatment
this is during clinical response and i
should say that the magnet the magnet uh
magnification is the same amongst all
these slides so this is the for for real
these cells are slightly smaller at
response we don't know why that is yet
and then at relapse we see the re
reentry of of nuclear 4e
so this led us to ask several questions
well indeed what controls the import of
nuclear 4e
um do cap or riboburn treatments lead to
a loss of nuclear 4e um we see that in
the patients but we didn't have a
molecular understanding of that and why
does effort go back into the nucleus at
clinical relapse and so this project has
been a
a big effort between
um my lab in particular and up around
tiki and zahara dean and morocco and
mike osborne and biliana as well as
human shook slab in dallas including
garen and jeremy
so
we first had to find out what was the
protein that was involved in importing
4e into the nucleus and we found
that important eight
is a traditional important
binds for e i should remind you for it
has no nuclear localization signal so
its ability to
to be imported is something that we are
investigating as you'll see
so it directly binds these are using
purified proteins important 8 directly
binds 4e you can see it absent from the
gst pull down
we can see here
that important 8 that in a nuclear in
vitro import assay
plus buffer use in this assay i should
also say that we're using fourier gst
that we've added exogenously and we're
using a gst antibody so you're only
looking at the exogenous 4e so here
you're seeing the exogenous 4e is
cytoplasmic but if we add important 8
now it's happily imported into the
nucleus
if we went on to try to understand a
little bit
more about the um
the
important fourier interaction and
particularly ask the question what is
the effect of binding methyl7 guanosine
cap and also ribovarian on the ability
of fourier and import nate to interact
it has clear implications for
for how 4e can function um how before
you can get imported
so what you're looking at here is an nmr
what we call hsqc spectrum of
4e where each of these peaks corresponds
to a single amino group rough roughly
speaking
and what we can see in is the apo is
well structured
but if we
if we
now add important eight you can see that
this
the spectrum in red we'll go back and
have another look we can't go back so
never mind um is that where you have the
red peaks are are the peaks when you
have
the fourier important eight complex and
what happens is important eight is 120
kilodaltons and 4e is 25 but the large
size of important eight slows down the
tumbling and makes the sample become
invisible sort of to nmr to a certain
extent so the only parts you can see are
the unstructured regions of 4e remaining
all the rest of the peaks are gone
if we now add
if we now add a cap
cap analog m7g cap analog
you can see in green that the peaks have
started they've returned and not only
that but they've returned in new
positions and these new positions
indicate that they're in their cap bound
form and so what's happened here is that
the addition of the cap has actually
disrupted the important 840 complex
so this really strongly suggests that
when fourier is cap bound meaning
physiologically when fouries binding rna
that it will not import it it will not
be imported because the important eight
cannot bind bind the rna
fourier complexes
so let's look into this a little more if
we do more of our nuclear import assays
we can see
um
all of this in the presence of important
a that clearly in the absence of of the
cap
you have a happy nuclear import whereas
if you add an excess of the cap now the
import is disrupted if we take a cap
binding mutant of 4e we can first of all
see interestingly that you require you
do not require cap binding to enter the
nucleus because this enters the nucleus
just as readily
pardon me as well type 4e
and since it doesn't bind the cap the
addition of the cap has no effect and
still it enters the the nucleus in its
cat-free state
so
what we can say here is that excess cap
impairs for a nuclear import
while the w56 cap binding mutant is
immune to this effect
so
because ribovarian triphosphate binds in
the same spot as for e and and as the
cap on 4e and causes similar
allosteric uh structural changes on the
surface of 4e we ask the question does
ribovaren impede this and could this
explain the phenotypes that we're seeing
in the patients
so in again in our control assay with
important mate we see 4e enter the
nucleus
however if we add a 50-fold excess of
ribogram triphosphate we now see
fluorine entry is impaired
and below it just for comparison is
again that same state a patient
micrographs
showing you what at clinical response we
observe which is very similar to what
you're seeing when you add excess rtp
here
so
what we asked next is what are the
physiological effects in modulating
important a and foreign trafficking in a
cell line model
so here we have
cells treated with either rna scramble
control or where important eight is
knocked down which you can see that
knocked down there and you can see quite
clearly that knocking down important
eight in in intact cells as opposed to
nuclear
in vitro nuclear import assay so these
are intact cells
substantially impairs nuclear entry
and this corresponds to reduction in the
production of rna export targets and
also of rna export activity as you would
expect since its absence
similarly if we over express important 8
we see an increase
in the
production of export targets such as
surviving and cement really suggesting
that
that increasing nuclear fourier in this
case is actually helping to to drive
proliferation
what we did to ask whether we could have
an effect
on
contact inhibition as our as our
surrogate for for like transformation
is we took uh and did sh rna of
important a and fourier over expressing
cells
so what you can see in controls b
c and a they're just all different shrna
controls that don't touch important
eight whereas if we knock down important
a we have a clear reduction in foci
number which is quantified here
really strongly suggesting that 4e
requires important 8 to be present in
order for it to transform cells
so what's our model so this is the
nuclear side and the cytoplasmic side
and what we see is obviously
um
when once the rnas get exported out
we can have the rnas free to go to the
translational machine ring but this
particular fourier rna complex is not a
cargo for important aid as we showed
with our cap and rtp experiments
when the rna is finally released then
important a combined 4e it also binds
brand gdp
um and and re-enter
being rna-bound or being right-over-rtp
bound prevents this association with
important a and thereby prevents nuclear
entry
um once we go to the nucleus
important a cargo
releases its 40 cargo through increased
rand binding again i didn't have time to
show you but this is definitely a random
dependent event
so and i i should also state
that one of the things that that we
observe in the patients
is that ribovarin actually gets modified
and so at relapse
the uh ribovarian can no longer bind 4e
putting it in a class that allows
re-entry into the nucleus
showing us why clinical relapses
associated with increased nuclear eif4e
so why do patients relapse
so obviously we get very excited when
our patients are doing well but we truly
feel
the that that we failed them when they
relapse
so
we decided to figure out
how exactly
this relapse um
why exactly are these patients relapsing
and in some cases why do patients with
have who have high four you never
respond to ribovarin in the first place
so we have to talk a little bit about
riboflavin metabolism to address these
questions
so here's the extra cellular at the
extracellular and the intracellular side
this is ribovarin it enters the cell
through the nucleoside transporter ent1
and it undergoes multiple uh
phosphorylation steps um the key one
being through adenosine kinase
and indeed if you knock down adenosine
kinase ribovarin
has a net uptake problem i.e the minute
that riboburn's not phosphorylated it's
is a good export target for for ent1 and
gets kicked back out of the cell
so we asked our we designed some cell
line model systems and we saw either
problems with ent1 or problems with adk
and so we looked at our patient
populations between our two trials which
number about 50 patients in total and
only two patients did we really see a
strong uptake phenotype as we would call
it
so
in patient 11 achieved to see the cr
from the first trial and you can see
over time so this is at 84 days and this
is rna
and this is at 252 days the the extent
to which the his levels of adenosine
kinase relative to control uh loading
control have been altered and similarly
we see a very big change in ent1 so this
patient had a substantial uptake problem
and that's probably why he stopped
responding to ribotherm
if we look at another patient from our
initial clinical trial
and look at adk levels in this
individual we can see that versus a
normal
specimen um that this patient had
substantial reduction about five-fold of
adk also suggesting that this patient
would have never responded because the
rabbit baron wouldn't have entered
entered into two cells
but these are the only two patients that
were really strong uptake and we wanted
to know what is that what's the
explanation for the the rest of the
patients why did they relapse and so
um we did a series of experiments to to
define what we refer to as type 2
resistance
um
which we refer to as as
cells or patients that have normal
uptake they have a loss of the fluoride
interaction and they have no detectable
mutation in 4e
so what's the evidence for that
first of all if we take our treated
ribovarian ip assay and we look at our
resistance cell lines in light blue and
pink versus our parental cell line we
see that the resistance cell lines have
a substantial reduction in the ability
of 4e to immunoprecipitate retritiated
ribovarin
and if we look at their overall uptake
well type 1 is that sort of 80k ent1
uptake mutation and has severely
impaired uptake we can see that
type 2 resistance which is this same
here
has normal uptake so this is not an
uptake issue this is really an issue
with the loss of the ability of the drug
to bind the target and as i said four e
levels um
were unchanged fourier was not mutated
and if you s i rna4e in these cells
they're still sensitive so they still
genetically rely on fluorine and this
made us lead us to decide that maybe it
was a rivalry that was modified rather
than before e
so what is causing this type 2
resistance we use deep sequencing
methods
um
and through this we observed
uh glee 1 the glioma associated protein
1
being highly elevated by 17 fold and
this is confirmed both at the western
level as well as at the rna level using
qpcr
what we've been able to show
is that we when over expression in
sensitive cells is sufficient to impart
resistance
the gliwin rnai mediated knockdown led
to reversion of resistance
the vismojib also known as gdc0449 which
is fda approved inhibitor of glee 1
reverse resistance in our cells
and
patients in
in the trial have elevated v1 upon
resistance and and in some cases prior
to treatment
so let's look at some of the data this
is looking at the total rna levels of
patients from our two trials
a subset of patients from our two trials
where we had material before treatment
at response and end of treatment and you
can see that the overriding trend with
glee one rna relative to healthy
volunteers is that uh relative to onset
of treatment you always have higher q1
at relapse
and
we ask well is is this something only
specific to our trials which include
right ovarian or could this be more
globally uh a more global thing so we
looked at as a set of patients at
relapse and diagnosis
for their glee one rna levels that had
only received standard of care error c
containing therapies and what you can
see is that seven out of the nine have
highly elevated glue one at relapse
relative to diagnosis although two two
do not so it's not everybody but in our
group it seems to be most patients
so if we we derive private variant
resistance cell lines or if we
overexpress glee one well what what
happens and what what are the
the um
the the data to support it so first of
all what i'm going to show you is a glee
one over expression is sufficient to
impart resistance to both ribovariant
and arising and that gluon knockdown
restores drug sensitivity and resistant
cells
so here you have either cell line
overexpressing vector or glee 1
and this is all compared to the
resistance cell lines that we derived by
long-term growth in riboduran
and what you can clearly see is that the
glee 1 and fr2 cells are resistant to
both ribovarian and are c relative to
the parental to the vector controls
similarly if we take glee 1 here and
knock it down
we can see um
that again the the cells here are are
resistant and light blue is the
resistant cells and the parental cells
in dark blue are sensitive to both
riboburn and area c
but if we do a combination of sig1
and private varic treatment now we
re-sensitize the cells
and we can actually correlate this
resensitization with the stat with the
status of the treated ribovarian fourier
interaction that we'll be monitoring by
ip
so
in this case for instance if you have
the vector the degree one or the
resistance cells what you note is that
the three one and resistance cells both
have a significant loss of treated rapid
red fluorine interaction
relative to the parental control
here if we take uh
if we if we look at the parental cells
and we look at the resistant cells and
then we take those resistant cells and
we treat them with si we knock down glue
one we can see a recovery of the treated
derivative fourier interaction
and finally if we take the drug gdc049
also known as vismajib in resistant
cells we can see here no no traded
ribovarian for the interaction here
treated ribovarian for interaction is
restored so we see a clear correlation
between the glu1 status and triggerated
rapid run fourier interaction in our
cells
so how does gleam 1 status affect
um drug metabolism or the fourier inter
40 uh
regular interaction i should say g1
status does not affect 40 levels
um
so this seems to be foreign dependent
and what we could clearly see is that
through our deep sequencing studies we
need to look is that um
glee one elevation causes an elevation
in enzymes called ugt1as which are
involved in glucoronidation of a wide
variety of xenobiotics and metabolites
and so what our model was is that we
went over expression in an indirect
manner leads to elevation of ugt1as and
this ultimately leads to rival formation
of ribovarian glucuronides which impair
the interaction with 4e
enabling cells to grow even in the
presence of high ribodurin
and i should also state that not all
glucaronidation leads to increased drug
reflux this is a common misconception
it can equally well change drug
targeting and in some cases it can
actually increase drug efficacy as it
does with morphine so this is a case of
drug degradation not affecting
drug reflux
so let me first show you that ug21a
levels correlate with glee 1.
so if we take our um
either parental cells or resistant cells
and you can either mock treat or treat
with acid luciferase and you can see
that
what happens when you treat with sig1 is
quite dramatic obviously you have a b1
reduction but similarly ugt levels go
way down
if we now look at the one over
expression by itself you can see v1 over
expression this is vector this is glee
one that you have substantial elevation
in ug21a levels simply by over
expressing glee one
and i don't have time to show you today
but ugt1a levels are highly elevated um
in the patients with high glee one that
i showed you earlier on and that's
published in our nature paper from the
summer if you wanted to go look
obviously we're anticipating those to
see this rhyming variant glucaranide and
the resistance and not the parental
cells and we used analytical mass
spectrometry techniques to see this
so here you can see the riboflavin
diphosphate which is one of the
ribovarian carbon fiber metabolites and
here in the resistant cells you see
right in glucuronide which is completely
absent in the parental cells
if we take purified 4e and purified drug
metabolites we wanted to directly see if
were proved that 40 whether for a binds
or investigate i should say well
therefore he binds raven variant and not
the right variant glucaranide
so we took 40 gst and tritiated by the
varian and we either had a buffer blank
or
what we found is that uh the i should
say that these are already enriched and
tritiated ribovarin so this is a
competition experiment and if we took
cold ribenburn or cold rtp we
successfully washed away
um the hot ribovarin gtp is our negative
control and it had no effect it gave the
same result as a blank
and what you can see is that the
right-of-way glucoranide also could not
compete for tritiated ribovarian
indicating that that the right of the
the riboflavin could not bind eif4e
consistent with our model
so pharmacological inhibition of glee
one represses um
ugt so we like instead of using glue one
knockdown we we used vismojib or dc 0449
the glee one inhibitor and i should say
it's not a directly what inhibitor it
inhibits the the receptors
so it's upstream of the glut1 pathway
and what you can clearly see
this drug gdc049 is already known to
surprisingly one levels and this
correlates to suppression and ugt and
you get a similar effect in the presence
or absence of of riboderm
um and what i have already shown you is
that this causes restoration of the four
e trigated ribovarian ip and now you no
longer have the right variance with
granada glucaronide by mass spec
so
finally this is looking the last data
slide is that um
we looked at primer we looked at the
effects of gluon inhibition in resistant
primary human aml specimens so we took
aml specimens from
patients that had failed therapy so this
is at relapse
and what we see is pretty expected in
terms of and i should say in blue are
just a comparative normal pvmcs
this is pretty much expected that in
essence these these cells aren't really
going to respond to too much drug and i
should note that gdc
or the glee one inhibitor by itself has
no effect
on
on cell growth or colony growth in this
case
um however in each of the case that we
add um
either the glu1 inhibitor or plus
ribovarian or the b1 inhibitor plus era
c
um and this is just done at two
different concentrations you can you can
see
that now you restore so you need to have
glue one inhibition in the presence of
the drug gluon inhibition by itself is
not sufficient we want an inhibition in
the presence of the drug that's getting
glucoramidated and i don't have time to
show you today but are see we can also
see the google ground adds four in these
cells
um this causes a reversal of the
gluconidation reactivation of the drug
and drug sensitivity
so as just a
our model which we call inducible drug
glucaronidation is the following
elevated glu1 leads to elevated ugtas
which leads to glucronidation
impairs the 4e interaction and allows
and allows enhanced growth and i should
say you could substitute
other drugs and targets in the same way
um to inhibit this
we use we one rna-i
we can use vismojib gdc-0449 or also a
v1 inhibitor that is direct inhibitor of
p1 called gantt 61. in this case we
reduce your gta levels we have impaired
drug modification drug granulation this
allows restored
drug targeting and impaired growth
so what can what can we conclude about
what i told you today is that the
nuclear functions of 4e
um ie rna export and its ability to
modulate nuclear pore is important to
its oncogenic activity in cell culture
and in patients
we are also able we are the first to
identify a pharmacological inhibitor for
a ribovariant and to target fourier
activity
in cancer
rabiuren treatment leads to to foray
targeting and clinical responses in
patients however those patients relapse
the control of foreign localization is
critical for its oncogenic activity and
nuclear entry of 4e is only when it's
rna free
and this localization closely correlates
with our with what we observed in
patients in in terms of the
the ability of ribovirin to change the
localization of 4e
we identified a new form of multi-drug
resistance and a way to target it
which is leading to a clinical trial
which we hope to open in november or
december
and one of the findings that i didn't
have a chance to really elaborate on but
i think it's important to leave you with
is that what our drug resistance studies
also show is that cancer cells
metabolize drugs drip differently
than than their normal counterparts or
even non-resistant cancer cells and i
guess that's something people should
consider in the
when drug when when doing drug design
and i'd like to take a moment to
acknowledge the lab some of which i did
during the course of this talk julianna
kochukovic
um has done an awesome job with with
regards to the rna export study you saw
um mike osborne and laurenville pond
have done an awesome job with yeah um
nmr studies import nate enoch was also
on the important eight project hibba did
a lot of the work on almost all of the
work on drug resistance our
collaborators uh sarit dasolin in
particular who's leading the clinton the
first two clinical trials and now the
third are collaborators at pharma
science who helped us with the
analytical mass spec that you've seen as
well as provider for trials and the
funding agencies and finally you for
your attention so thank you very much
and i'll take questions online now
so i don't seem to have a
any any questions online
i guess i can wait
for for a minute or two and then
if not you can always uh
email and and
ask questions
uh that way
okay well well thank you very much
i'm
finished i